than uh participants joining
it's probably a heavier tail
and the patience hopefully won't burn
out
with me or with the participants
it was don't worry people are muted
there was a lot of laughter
i could i could tell
sorry present i didn't get it what did
you say
i took the analogy further if he waits
too long
some kernels burn okay so yeah let's get
started uh yeah it's a pleasure to uh to
have sravas here uh
who will tell us about sparse
reconstruction for uh hadamard matrices
or sampling from adam martin matrices
so yeah um so thanks for having me
thanks for the organizers for uh
putting this on i was super excited to
maybe be in berkeley now but you know
i'm glad that we're still
um doing this workshop through soon cool
so as uh james said i'm going to be
talking about this paper
and improved lower bound for sparse
reconstruction from sub-sampled hadamard
matrices
and this is based on joint work with a
bunch of people including yara cell
blasiac
patrick lopato kyle la and jake marsnick
so before i get started i just want to
mention a few things um first the
paper that this is based on is a little
bit short so definitely like don't be
shy and asking questions we definitely
have
lots of time to answer questions and
then the other thing i'll mention is
that
i'm going to talk about sort of a few
warm-up ideas
um that aren't in our paper before we
actually talk about the ideas in the
paper
um so probably we won't actually talk
about how to run matrices until
say halfway through but i'll bring that
up so that way you know um
what to expect cool so let's get started
um so basically the object we're going
to study are the set of ksps vectors
and they're going to live in say a big n
dimensional vector space
once we start talking about how to mark
matrices it might be helpful to
index our coordinates by vectors and say
f2 to the n
so for now we'll just stick with a
capital n dimensional vector space
but when we talk about hammer matrices
will be useful to say talk um it will be
useful to index the vector
index that coordinates by f2 to the n
cool and there's a few reasons why we
might care about ksrs vectors
one reason is that you know many real
world vectors are
are sparse um cool and then another
reason and i don't know if this is like
a real reason this is
maybe the reason i'm a little bit
interested in sort of studying kids
vectors is that you know these vectors
have a bound on say the ratio between
the l1 norm and the l2 norm
um right and if we sort of extend you
know our object to say all vectors that
have a bound on the ratio between the l1
norm and l2 norm
um a lot of the upper bounds to hold and
of course you know for lower bounds
if we consider more you know if we
extend our space of vectors that we're
considering
um you know that's not going to hurt
anything
and sort of the question we're going to
ask is how can we embed ksrs vectors in
a smaller dimensional vector space
while still preserving the geometry
right so these
various vectors are vectors with a lot
of zeros
right a lot of these coordinates are
zeros and you know when we're looking at
any say single k
sparks vector it feels like maybe we're
wasting a lot of space right because
there's there's a lot of zeros um on the
other hand it kind of also feels like
well we need every single coordinate
because
we won't necessarily know which
coordinates are non-zero
right you know it could be any any set
of say
um k coordinates can be not zero
well so we can ask this question well
like how by how much can we actually
sort of um um
well how can we embed these characters
vectors in a smaller solid
space
cool and sort of the property we're
going to be looking at is something
called the restricted isometry property
um this was introduced by candice and
tao and what this says is that if you
have a matrix a
this matrix when you multiply by a
dimensional vector is going to give you
a q dimensional vector
we say it satisfies the restricted
isometry property of order k
with constant epsilon if for all k
sparse vectors
the l2 norm of a times x squared is
approximately equal to
the l2 norm of x squared
cool so basically if we multiply this
matrix a by
a case first vector we're going to
approximately um
preserve the l2 norm
squared well so in some sense it's like
an isometry but just
this guarantee is only 4k squares
vectors
um one thing that i think it's helpful
for me at least when i'm thinking about
this is to maybe
think it's like the opposite of
normalize but um say look at sort of um
the l two norm squared of a times x
divided by q
and i think this is nice for me at least
um because
uh what we can do is we can say say that
if we look at
a times x and we look at this as a
vector basically a typical coordinate
of a times x should be um approximately
equal to the l two norm of x
and but yeah this is just a difference
in a normalization
cool and sort of the big question we can
ask is how small can q be
right the smaller qb sort of the smaller
the dimensional space
just so the smaller of a dimension that
we can embed these
kids bars vectors too
cool and i'll talk a little bit about
sparse reconstruction but i'm going to
mostly just focus on this idea of the
restricted isometry property
what candice in tow showed was that you
know if a satisfies the restricted
symmetry property of order 2k
and given a times x one can efficiently
recover x if x is say k sparse
um and as i mentioned you know this has
lots of applications
um so this is something that uh yarek
told me and i don't know if
i mean he told me so i haven't like
exactly verified it
but one thing he mentioned is that like
a lot of um the math that goes into say
um sparks recovery and what we're
talking about today um
also maybe got used in say getting this
picture of this black hole that was i
think a big deal about a year ago
so this is something like he told me so
i can't verify it for sure but
you know these are some of the
applications of what we're talking about
today
um are there any questions so far
so the first thing i'll talk about is
this lower bound due to garnet and
pluskin
and what they showed was that for any
matrix a um
that satisfies the restricted isometry
property it has to have at least
k log n over k roots
cool so i'm going to switch to
onenote and talk about this for a little
bit
and uh yeah
and let me know if i need to write
bigger or anything
so let me first rewrite the definition
of the restricted
symmetry property right so what we want
our vector
a whatever we want our matrix a to do is
when we multiply a times
x and we look at the l2 norm squared and
let's just divide by q we want this to
be equal to say
one plus or minus uh epsilon times
the l2 norm of x squared very quickly
from
brief instructions and explanations
others have made similar points
sorry i couldn't hear you
uh sorry
that seemed incidental i also couldn't
understand it so i muted them
but uh yeah they can try again
cool yeah maybe maybe i'll keep going um
right in x is
uh k squares
right in the theorem that i just put up
on the screen was that
q has to have at least say
k log n over k rose
well and i think yeah i forgot to
mention this earlier but for this talk
we're not going to worry too much about
the dependence on epsilon
right so you could you know ask you know
how does q depend on epsilon
we're not going to worry about that
today but that is something that maybe
people care about
cool so one thing we can do just to
first you know get started and thinking
about what's going on is try to see what
happens when we
consider say two specific vectors let's
say
x1 and x2
we can let x1 be the vector with
first k over two coordinates one in the
restaurant zero
and x2 is going to be the vector where
the first character coordinates are zero
and the next k over two coordinates are
one and the rest are all zero
one we can ask okay what happens right
so these are both case bars vectors what
happens when we
multiply a by these vectors
right and we know that when we multiply
a by x one if we look at the l two
number of that squared divided by
q that should be approximately equal to
say also the l 2 norm square root of 8
times x 2 divided by q right the d
should both be equal approximately two
one plus or minus epsilon times k over
two
right these vectors have um l2 norm k
over two so when we multiply by
a and say normalized by q um
they should also have norms say
approximately k over 2.
well so what this means is that you know
these vectors they have to live in a
ball of approximately k
over two right they can't right when we
look at a times x1 and a times x2 they
can't be
too far away from the origin
on the other hand we can also look at
say the difference
between a x1 and ax2
right we can look at the distance
between these two vectors
right this is equal to a times
x1 minus x2
x1 minus x2 is also k sparse right so
this property of the
this restricted isometry property still
tells us something about
you know what the l2 norm squared of a
times x1 minus x2 is
right in particular it should be
approximately equal to
one plus or minus epsilon
times k
okay so in particular a x one
and a times x two they should lie in a
ball
of radius
say approximately square root of k over
two but they should also be far apart
from each other
right this restricted x boundary
property says it's that um the distance
between a times
x one and a times x two have to be
pretty large it should be about
a square root of k
when we can maybe continue this we can
maybe let x sub i
be equal to the vector where we have a
bunch of zeros
then a bunch of ones and then a bunch of
zeros again
which may be the first k over two
times i minus one will be zeros then we
have the next k
over two coordinates will be one and the
last last coordinates will be zero
right and all everything we said for x
one and x two
applies for all pairs of x i right
all x i a times x i must be in a ball
the same ball of radius square root of k
over two but they should also be all
simultaneously far apart from each other
right the distance between a times x i
and a times x j
has to be pretty large it has to be
about um
square root of k
so we know that there's n over k such
x i
and so we can get maybe a lower bound of
q equals
log of n over k by a volume argument
right each of these a times x i's must
live in a ball
um of a big enough radius and none of
the other a times x i's
can be in that symbol because right
because if they were in that same ball
they would be too close to that of the
first a times x a
cool so this gives you this gives us a
lower bound of log of n over k
and what i promised you was a lower
bound of
k times log of n over k um so there's
one
slight modification we can do
we can maybe
allow these um af x guys to be a little
bit closer to each other
right basically you know when we looked
at the original a of xi's they all had
to have a distance of
you know about square root of k from
each other right and they were basically
all
non-sparks on different coordinates
cool so then maybe if we say allow
the distance between x sub i and x sub j
squared to maybe instead of having to be
exactly k we can let it be
k over c for some constant k
for some constant c
and this will be for all i and j
then in this case we can come up with
say
n over k to the omega of k
such x i
and the same properties still hold right
these a times x i still have to live in
a ball
and the distance between any pair of a
x i and a x j has to be still pretty
large maybe not
square root of k anymore but now it's
going to be about square root of k over
c
and then by the same volume argument we
get the slower bound of
k times log of n over k since we have
that many more vectors
cool so are there questions about this
so i'll go back to
the slides
cool so now we have our lower bound
right and this lower bound is going to
be for any
um that satisfies a restricted isometry
property
cool so now we'll start talking about
you know approaches for an upper body
you know what are some
actual matrices that might satisfy the
restricted isometry property
cool and one first step that we can take
is you know we can maybe let the entries
of a
be um uh uniform and independently
uniform over one plus minus one and they
should obviously also be independent
entries
um right this is maybe kind of a natural
idea
and you know it turns out that this
works and um
you know what we can show is that if q
um
is right if we have say k log n entries
um then you know a actually satisfies
the restricted isometry property of
order k
right so this means that if the entries
of a are uniform
over plus minus one then we can actually
get sort of an optimal
um uh matrix that satisfied the
restricted graviton
our property are we going to get a
matrix that says rfp with an optimal
number of rows
um cool so i'll talk about this
um
and i'll go back to
one note
so i'll just rewrite the definition of
the restricted isometry property we want
the l2 norm squared of a times x to be
approximately equal to 1 plus or minus
epsilon of the l2 norm of x
when x is k sparse
cool and now we're going to let a have
um
uh entries that are going to be id over
plus minus 1.
and what we're going to show is that if
we have say on
c times k times log n entries
i mean uh rows that's that's actually
enough
so we can take a look at what this
matrix looks like
right as plus minus ones everywhere
and we can maybe for now just focus on
what happens when we multiply it
by a single single case for us vector
also for simplicity we'll like uh
we'll let the non-sparse entries or the
non-zero entries be
their first k and we'll let
the last entries all be zero
and this is going to give us a q
dimensional vector
and let's call these entries a 1 all the
way up to
a q
and we can take a look at you know
specifically what one of these ai's
looks like
well so one specific ai is going to look
like you know plus minus
x1 plus minus x2
and so on all the way up to k
where the plus minus our id
all right so this is a random variable
that we know pretty well
right in particular we know that the a
of i are distributed
like a gaussian
centered at zero and with standard
deviation
x1 squared plus x2 squared
oh sorry
all the way up to x k squared
let me start to rewrite this
cool and sort of the actual value we're
looking at is
you know the value a1 squared plus
a2 squared all the way up to
aq squared right this is going to be
equal to
um a times x the alternative of a times
x squared
uh and we're dividing by q
and if we sort of do the computations it
turns out that this concentrates
around
the l2 norm square root of x right x1
squared
plus x2 squared all the way up to
xk squared
in particular if we say look at the
probability
that you know our l2 norm of the
resulting vector a times x
divided by q is not
you know good enough to satisfy the
restricted isometry property for the
specific x
right so it's not equal to say plus
minus
sorry 1 plus or minus
epsilon times the l2 norm of x
where this is bounded above by some
exponential
times some function of epsilon
times q
well so this is an upper bound that we
get for some
right that we failed to satisfy the
restricted isometry property for one
specific
um vector x
well i think one thing just to maybe
like quickly point out is that you know
what this is kind of saying
is that you know we need say a constant
for all we care about is just one vector
x
um we only need to say a constant um
number of samples or we need
a only needs a constant number of rows
for us to satisfy the restricted
isometry property
well so this will be a sort of a
contrast for when we talk about
stop sampling kind of our matrices um
but yeah
cool so this is just for one vector x
and you know it turns out that it's
enough
to consider
a net
of all case first vectors
right because if once we have a net of
all k squares vectors we can say that
for every
for every k sparse vector
it'll be close to one of these vectors
internet
all right so as long as we satisfy the
restricted solution property for the
vector that it's close to we'll also
satisfy the restriction of some entry
for
um this case for us vector
and the size of this note is going to be
n to the k
this is going to be the number of
choices
for non-zero entries
times some polynomial
and say k times one over epsilon
so we can do a union bound over all the
vectors in our net
and that's going to give us a total
probability of n to the k
oh sorry paulie k 1 over epsilon also to
the k
since the total bottom the failure
probability is going to be added to the
k
times poly of k times
1 over epsilon to the k
times e to the minus sign
f of epsilon times q cool and this will
be small
if q is say
equal to c times k
times log of capital f
well and again i'm ignoring sort of the
dependence on epsilon so
you know there should be some epsilon in
this constant um
but otherwise it's just going to be you
know k times like
cool sorry are there questions about the
upper bound for
independent entries
cool so let's go back to the slides
right so just to recap what we've done
we've shown a lower bound of
k log n um and we've shown the upper
bound of k log n
right so this kind of seems like we've
done we're done right we've found
you know how to come up with matrices
that sort of do as good as you can when
we're trying to satisfy the restricted
isometry property
um but there are a few few issues um
with sort of having our entries be
completely random um one is that it
requires a lot of randomness
right we need a different um you know we
need a random bid for every single entry
and also when we're actually doing the
multiplication
of a times sort of our k-sparse vector
right this multiplication will be slow
because there's really
you know we don't have any structure in
our matrix a
right it's completely random um and
basically the counterpart is you know
when we start talking about how to our
matrices
there's a way to do multiplication where
it's much faster
right and because we are using these for
like you know taking pictures of black
holes
or you're constructing pictures of black
holes like we want fast multiplication
cool so at this point i'm going to start
talking about how to move matrices which
is
what the subject of the corresponding
papers about
cool so there's a few way ways you can
define how to run matrices
one is this recursive definition where
maybe we start with h of one it's just
going to be the
one by one matrix that's one and then we
define h of n to be this block matrix
where
the you know the upper
right upper left and bottom left blocks
are h of n minus one
and the bottom right block is minus h of
minus
minus h of x
when at this point it will be super
useful to index or coordinates by
f of two to the n rather than capital n
um and the reason for this is that you
know if you look at say
um sorry there should be h of n but you
know if we look at say h of n if we look
at the icon which is
um um
entry of this matrix this is going to be
equal to one
minus one to the inner product of i and
j
right so this will be useful when
thinking about having our matrices
um however matrices are an isometry
right when we want to play a hadamard
matrix by itself it's equal to the
identity
and then what this means is that you
know sampling enough rows of h should
work
right so it's maybe not super clear that
you know um we can get even close to
like k log in but
you know let's say if we sample enough
um enough rows that we sample like each
row many different times
that should at least give us a matrix
that satisfy their restricted isometry
properties i'm going to be a very good
one but
um you know it would work
cool so just to sort of write down what
this matrix a looks like
when we're sampling rows of our hat or a
matrix we're basically
sampling um you know q vectors
s1 through sq they're going to be
uniform and independent over f
mod 2 to the n and if we look at say the
a
i comma j of entry of a that's going to
be equal to minus 1 to the inner product
of s of i
and j
cool so this is basically what our
matrix looks like when we're sampling
the rows of our head of our matrix
well so the rows of a are rows of h of n
and one thing to kind of keep in mind is
that the columns of a are very very
dependent right once we know say the
column corresponding to
vector one comma zero and so on and the
column of corresponding to the vector is
zero comma one comma zero and so on
that's going to tell us exactly what the
one comma one comma zero
column is i mean that's because of the
structure
structure of a cool so a lot of the
techniques we use when we're analyzing
say
matrices where the entries are
completely independent won't work
here
but what's kind of kind of nice is that
we're still able to get pretty close to
this k
log n lower bound right so what candace
and tao showed was that
we can actually get um you know this
actually gives us a matrix to satisfy
the restricted isometry property
if we have um if we sample k times log
to the sixth of n rows
and then people improved this over a
long series of work
um rudel cinema shinin um got an upper
bound of k
log n log square k lock k log n
um truck [ __ ] swami valencia got an
upper round of k log cubed k log in
bourgain got an upper bound of k log k
log squared of n
which i think is incomparable to the
previous upper bound by character
and then uh have even i've got an upper
bound of k log
squared k log n um which is better than
the previous upper bound because k
is less than n right so we kept
decreasing
and decreasing and getting closer and
closer to k log n
right so i mean i think when i saw this
i was like okay well like
you know k log n seems actually like
quite plausible
for how to put i don't know if this was
me being naive or
you know i don't necessarily know what
people actually taught but
one one you know maybe you can think you
know basically looking at
these series of work is that you know
eventually we'll get to kayla again
even for sub-sampled having more
matrices
cool and what what we showed was that
you know you actually need
k log k log n um
samples uh yeah they think this should
be updated but
if k is bigger than like say log to the
c of n or
um this should really be k times min of
n over k
um right but basically you know in a lot
of
for a lot of settings of k you actually
need k
log k log n samples in order to
satisfy the restriction isometric
property
cool so i'll talk a little bit about the
ideas and the proof of this
so let me just actually write the
definition of the restricted
symmetry property again right we want
the l2 norm of a times x
to be approximately equal to one plus or
minus
epsilon times the l2 norm of x
right and in this particular setting um
as
we have s1 s2 all the way up to sq
they're uniform and independent
over f mod 2
to the n and in particular
a of i comma j is going to be equal to
minus 1
to the inner product of s of i and j
right in particular is going to be a
matrix
whose rows are indexed by q whose
columns are indexed by
f mod 2 to the n
cool so you know we can try the same
approach as
before where maybe we can first focus on
a specific
k-sparse vector so let's let x be our k
as far as vector
and think about what happens when we're
multiplying a by x
but you know as i mentioned before this
time it really really matters
uh which uh which coordinates are
the ones that are non-zero i'm right
because
this kind of tells us a lot of right and
just yeah it matters more than in the
depending case
so as a first step we can consider the
case where the non-zero coordinates
are say basis vectors right so let's say
they're e1
e2 all the way up to ek
right so where you want to say 1 comma 0
and so on
e2 is going to be say 0 comma 1
times 0 and so on
and if we look at what a times x
if we look at the jth coordinate of this
what this is going to look like
is -1 to the inner product of
s j comma e one times x one
plus minus one to the inner product of s
j comma e two
times x two and so on and so forth all
the way up to
minus one to the inner product of s j
com e k
times x k
and basically you know all of these
minus ones the sj
comma e1 minus one to the sj comma e2
and so on
these are all going to be randomly plus
minus one and they're all going to be
independent of each other
right we're picking these sj's uniformly
over f2 to the n
right and basically the inner product of
sj and e1 is going to be
the first coordinate of sj the inner
product of sj and e2 is going to be the
second coordinate of sj and so on and so
forth
right and obviously the first coordinate
of sj has nothing to do with the second
coordinate of sj
and the second coordinate of sj has
nothing to do with third coordinate sj
these are all completely independent so
the analysis here is the same
as in the case of iid entries
cool in particular what this means is
that you know we don't want to focus on
these vectors
when we're trying to say come up with
this better lower bound
so the next maybe set of well the other
set of
non-zero accordions we can try um are
ones that
maybe make up a subspace
all right so maybe we can think of say
the coordinates corresponding to
the zero vector e1 e2
all are up to e of log k
and then say e1 plus e2
e1 plus e3 and so on
all the way up to e1 plus e2
uh to e of log k
all right so in particular this might be
kind of this might correspond to a
subspace
v of dimension
log k
cool in particular we can also just
let's say x be a zero one vector
okay so we'll let x be the vector where
it's one where it corresponds to uh
uh element in the subspace and zero
otherwise
right just to make things a little bit
even simpler
well so if we do the computation and
look at a
times x and look at the jf coordinate
this is just going to be equal to the
sum of all vectors
v in our vector space of the inner
product of
one minus of minus one to the inner
product of
s of j comma v
well now we have two cases
if the inner product of s of j
comma v
is equal to zero for
all um
sorry i've asked inner product of s j
comma e of i
is equal to zero for all i and say
one through log k
right then a times x
the jth coordinate is going to be equal
to k exactly
right because everything we're adding up
here is going to be 1.
the other case and otherwise we know
that the inner product of sj
and ei is equal to
one for some i
and basically we know that the inner
product of sj
and v is not equal to the inner product
of sj
and e of i
for all for all the inner vector space
all right so this means that when we're
adding adding up when we're looking this
sum for every minus one
there's also a plus one right and in
this case
a times x the jth coordinate is going to
be equal to
zero
cool so in general if we um
look at the say any specific coordinate
of a times x
this is going to be equal to k with
probability
one over k right we have the s of j
and e of i the inner product of this is
zero for all
i with probability one over two to log k
or one over k
and otherwise it's going to be zero
well so what this means is that we're
pretty likely to get
you know when we're looking at the
specific vector x and we're looking at a
times x
we're very likely to get a lot of zeros
right and if we only get zeros that
means that we're multiplying when we're
multiplying a times
x we're getting a vector that's zero
this is not anywhere close to
the l2 norm squared of x right so this
is really bad we're not going to satisfy
the restricted isometry property
if when we multiply by k sparse vector
we're going to get a zero
but the thing is that a times x
is going to equal zero with probability
one minus one over k to the q
which is approximately equal to um
e to the minus q over k
right and if a times x is equal to zero
we
don't satisfy
rip right we're pretty far from it
well so the intuition i mean i had when
i was thinking about this is that okay
this is the case for
one specific subspace
of dimension log log k there's something
like say
n to the omega log k
subspaces
of dimension log k
right and let's say we try to do a union
bound this would give us
say n to the log k
times e to the minus q over k
right and this kind of means that q is
should be at least
k log n log k
well so in particular you know for each
one of these subspaces we need
you know say k samples
in order to get something that's even
non-zero
right if we kind of try to do a union
bound over say all
and to the log k subspaces of dimension
log k
this means that you know we kind of need
k times log n times log k
samples in order to make sure that just
none of these vectors
are zero we multiply them by our
potential
rip matrix
cool sorry for scrolling down like this
um well obviously the issue with this is
that
the union bound is an upper bound
right so this doesn't actually give us
anything that we can work with
um but instead we can just get around
this by using the principle of inclusion
exclusion
or the second moment method
both will end up giving us the right
lower bound that we need
um cool so in particular the
the dilemma that helps us here is that
if we know that
say the dimension of two the
intersection of two subspaces
is say less than or equal to log k over
two
then a times the indicator vector of the
first subspace
being equal to zero and a times the
indicator vector of the second
substitutes being equal to zero
um they'll be close to being independent
they won't be totally independent but
they're
they'll be close enough because their
intersection of the
uh subspaces is has a small dimension
and this will be this will be enough to
give us some
a lower bound on the probability um
sorry a lower bound on the probability
that
one of these vectors is equal to zero or
one of these a times x's is equal to
zero
right and if a times x is equal to zero
this is really bad and we don't satisfy
the restricted isometric property
cool are there questions about any of
this
cool enough questions uh-huh let's go
back to the slides
cool so this is our lower bound um so
let me talk
briefly about um ideas for future work
um
one one thing to think about is how can
we close the gap between upper and lower
bound for head and matrices
all right so even though this upper
bound was k log squared k
log n the lower bound we showed was k
log k log n
right so it might be nice to have a
matching upper and lower bound
um another thing is you know can we do
balance for the fourier transform versus
mutton right so the habanero matrix is
basically a fourier transform of our f
bond two to the end um right and this
lower bound is very specific for
hadamard matrices
right if you try to do the same lower
bound for the fourier transform over z
button or if you try the same exact
ideas um it won't work
um so it might be nice to come up with
um
maybe balance for fourier transform over
z mode um i should mention that all of
the upper bounds i
mentioned previously do also apply for
the fourier transform reversing mode
so the upper bounds still apply the
lower bounds don't
um but the original like k log n still
applies
going the last thing that might be nice
is maybe more like say explicit
constructions
of matrices that satisfy the restricted
isometry property
most of the constructions i gave are all
um randomized so maybe it's nice to have
say
explicit constructions
cool and uh yeah that's it
all right thanks for the nice talk um we
have
a few minutes for questions if anyone
has one
so let me i'll ask actually about uh
your your first uh question there so the
so
you gave a lower bound uh right which is
essentially
i mean you get you presented as a
counting argument but some analytic
version of this counting argument
um do you know i mean
at least if i remember correctly from
[Music]
a long time ago the upper bounds also
you can sort of
phrase them as sort of
uh combinatorial argument and then you
have to do the analytic versions
of those things to get uh upper bounds
uh
like says can you i mean can you state
where the gap is between
the upper bound the log k squared and
your lower bound
like sort of which events
sort of seem problematic
yeah so i kind of remember exactly how
like the upper bounds go
um
right so all the all the upper bounds
are they're like a chaining arguments
um so somehow like they don't really
take into account like
you know the difference between say if
like the non-zero coordinates are all
um say independent of each other versus
if they're all um
ksa come from a subspace
right they kind of try to remember
exactly um
yeah i mean i think essentially if they
kind of like treat like all chaos bars
factors the same
and they do some sort of chaining
argument that i think like um
maybe like implicitly like kind of deals
with this a little bit
but um not like
exactly and i think you know one thing
that might be kind of nice is if like
you know you can say like um you can
sort of deal with say like
every um set of say
uh possible nonzero coordinates
differently right so on one hand for the
end
like if they're all independent like you
know we don't have any work there
on the other hand um for the case where
they all come from a subspace
um you know there's i mean there's a
uh there are like end to the lucky but
there's not more
maybe there's a way to say interpolate
between these two
um but i think from what i remember for
the upper bounds
they don't really differentiate between
these two
cases beyond say maybe like anything
that's implicit from the chaining
arguments
[Music]
okay if we don't have any more questions
then
we have three minutes until uh wait we
have more time in that we have eight
minutes
until uh sam's talk
so feel free to chat until then